good morning good afternoon good evening
depending on where you're joining us
from welcome to simply learn we are
honored to have you join us today for
radical analytics uncover blind spots in
your organization's data pyramid with
your host Stefan hemel my name is
Richard and after this intro I'll be
mostly in the background helping Stefan
so that everything goes smoothly until
the last 15 minutes we'll do the
question and answer and try to answer
all the questions we can during the
session radical analytics uncover blind
spots in your organization's data
pyramid web in digital analytics for
over the 10 years has been an infant
stage just at the beginning some of it
works some of it is still not working
but we're still using them and the
question is where can we grow the
industry and where does it need to be
improved if you do not know Stefan
Stefan is a seasoned independent
consultant and distinguished thought
leader in the field of digital analytics
recognized as a google google product
strategy expert and considered one of
the most influential industry
contributors by the digital analytics
Association not some [ __ ] he has made
significant contributions to the
industry including creating the digital
analytics maturity model in the web
analytics solution profiler wasp Quality
Assurance tool as well as other tools
and concepts throughout the years Stefan
previously had a leadership position
with the award-winning Cardinal pathogen
see board positions with the DAA Stefan
has taught hundreds of students and
co-manages the largest Google Analytics
user community on Google+ and serves on
a number advisory boards for agencies
startups and vendors in digital
analytics industry we're really lucky to
have its defined today here in this
expertise for those who aren't familiar
with this form of webinar I want to
introduce you to your dashboard if
everyone could locate your dashboard and
then locate the question module and go
ahead and type in hello in the question
module you might have to click on the
red arrow to re-expand it if it's a
minimized this lets us know that you're
listening that you can hear us okay and
the speaker systems are up because the
chance just to double-check everything
on our side and thank you for being here
Andrew
Tomas great to have you we're excited to
have everybody here today this is going
to be your best friend during the
webinar if you can go ahead and just
pull up your questions and go ahead and
put them in there anything about your
own career choice the company you're in
your own personal path we have a nice
wonderful professional today who's going
to help with those questions and at the
end the last 15 minutes we'll go through
a question and answer period and we'll
try to get to as many of those questions
as we can and again Carl thank you hello
enroll enroll SP I'm not sure that is
all good morning if you hear something
awesome brilliant interesting insightful
and you want to share in your social
channels whatever your social channels
are facebook linkedin tweet you can use
the hashtag SL webinars that way people
can find it you'll make them wish they
were here you didn't come here to listen
to me I'm proud to introduce to fajn
will be your host for radical analytics
uncover blind spots in your
organization's data pyramid go ahead and
sit back relax have a cup of coffee tea
or if it's evening where you're at maybe
a glass of wine and enjoy it's an honor
for me to hand this over to staff on
thank you and happy learning hello
Stefan and welcome to simply learn today
hello were rich hard how are you i am
doing excellent this up for me wonderful
morning let me go ahead you have people
from I think we have people from India
we have people from a little bit all
over so that's that's pretty exciting
yes oh I love that part about this job
we get to see any such an array of
people across the globe definitely
learning go ahead i shall and let you
get started alright thank you so let's
go with this this topic of radical
analytics where we're going to go
through a number of points that I've
been uncovering over the years so we've
been as an industry we've been doing
webinar takes or digital analytics for a
good 10 years and over those those years
there's things that works and there's
sadly many things that still don't work
even after 10 years so we're going to
talk about the concept of radical and
optics which is something I've put
forward based on my own research and my
own interest in the field so what is
radical analytics then we're going to
look at how we can apply the concept to
define some goals and KPIs and of course
what I want you to have in mind is that
nothing is perfect so I'm going to make
some suggestions I'm going to talk about
some examples but really what's the most
important is your critical thinking
don't take everything for granted
there's no magic recipe but hopefully
there are some good ideas that you're
going to be able to to learn and apply
in your own environment so one of the
thing that I've learned and if you have
some experience in web analytics or if
you are in digital marketing a wonderful
question we always ask is what are your
objectives and it usually starts with
well you know are we talking about a
business objective are we talking about
maybe my own managers objectives or are
we talking about maybe something that is
more personal in my professional life or
even my personal life about a personal
objective so how do we start where do we
go with that you know how do we start
we've heard about smart objectives how
to define an objective that would be a
simple and measurable and and you know
the acronym is is pretty well known yet
in the field I rarely see people
actually going through all of the steps
required to define a smart objective
even if we know that it would be very
useful then there's other techniques
like the 5w and one age which is a bit
like what investigators would do in the
police or journalists they would ask
they would try to make a story where
they understand what is going what is
the de subject matter who is involved
when was it where it was why it happened
and and how it happened so did this
would be an investigation technique to
the front objective which you know might
be useful
then politics gets involved and we have
to make up an objective we have to guess
what is the objective and we we get
asked you know if you could do something
like this would you have something to
celebrate or you know simply what is
your managers how is your managers bonus
determine so all of that I've heard and
many other examples of how we try to
define objective the simple truth is
that when we ask someone either my
clients or when I talk to other people I
ask them what what's your objective
usually they simply don't know they they
will make up something they will think
of something to define it too because
they don't want to look stupid they
don't want to look dumb so if you ask
someone what's your objective rest
assure that they will tell you something
maybe not the right thing but you're
going to be stuck with that because you
just open the door so you know I've seen
that so often that I started thinking
okay well there's something wrong here
we need to do something about it if we
take another example um we've heard
about the concept of the elevator pitch
and as a digital analyst as a marketer
you need to bring value to the
organization and it when if I was to ask
you know what what is your current
measurement framework an analysis
process what are the steps that you go
through in order to bring value to the
organization well most likely it's not
something that you always think about
then there was there was this other
interesting point recently someone asked
what is your number one strategy to
define actionable kpi's so in tinkering
if we as an industry if we've been
working and trying to define kpi's for
the past 10 to 15 years and even longer
than that because kpi's existed long
before the web right
so we should have a recipe we should
have clearly defined steps to define
good great KPIs that are really relevant
well the reality is when 42 different
people were asking and 42 people who are
seasoned people in the industry they
were asked what is their number one
strategy I was really really surprised
to see 42 different answers so even as a
group even as an industry we haven't
figured out how to define great kpi's
this is really troublesome so that's why
I came out with the concept of radical
and analytics and at first some people
said well you know isn't it a bit too
radical listen isn't it a bit too
crunchy or too hard well I think the
important aspect is we're talking about
a radical overhaul of the existing
framework so what can we do differently
in order to have greater success so if
we've been doing doing it the same way
for a number of years and it doesn't
work maybe it's about time that we try
something different and all of this work
stems from the work that I've done on
the concept of digital analytics
maturity since 2009 so back in the days
in 2009 I was completing my MBA and in
the industry the word was web analytics
is hard and I couldn't accept that
statement for me if something is is hard
it's something something is difficult
it's it's just a good challenge we it
means there's an important you to do
something different so I was more of the
school of thought that okay maybe it's
hard maybe it's difficult but what are
we doing about it and studying what
other maturity models order concepts I
came up with a proposal for the digital
analytics maturity model which at first
maybe wasn't received in the market
in a way that was really expecting but
recently over the recent years everybody
talks about maturity which is
interesting because it took all that
time to get there and in the concept of
digital analytics maturity you have five
areas and coincidentally it you know if
you if you are able to align all of
those five attributes you're going to be
a superstar in in this digital analytics
industry so the first one is governance
culture and adoption so what is the
current governance what is the current
is the organization data-driven you know
that's usually what we say so we start
from somewhere the second dimension is
what is the scope what is the playing
field that is involved are you trying to
optimize and measure just marketing
campaigns or are you trying to do it
globally for several brands across you
know different products with tons of
different stakeholders so the scope is
the size of the playing field and of
course how do you define your objective
what does success look like then the
turn one is the team in it ND expertise
which kind of resources do you have do
you have a great team internally what
kind of training they need what are
their strengths and weaknesses do you
need to rely on external consultants and
other partners then the other one is
what is a continuous improvement process
methodology that you use to do analytics
and there is a benchmark that I've
created and honestly this area is always
the weakest spot so we're we have
difficulties being systematic and being
able to when we find a right way to do
something being able to reproduce
success reproduce same steps then we go
into the last one which is about the
tools the data and the technology so
none of those five areas is more
important than another but I would say
that
the technology you use it in the tools
you have in the data you have is not a
strong will not have a strong impact on
your ability to bring value to the
organization it's not about the tools
you have it's about your ability to
leverage those tools so I've seen
organization do amazing things with
simple tools and live in small data and
they were able to bring a lot of value
to the organization so again it's it's
how you're able to align those five
dimensions on a scale of 0 to 5 with
different criteria and if you if you see
an organization that is that is very
very ambitious let's say on the scope
and objectives dimension they are super
ambitious but the other aspects are
lower on the maturity scale then your
chances of success are very very weak
you're aiming for trouble and and so on
for the other dimension so the goal is
if you have one area or maybe two areas
that are way higher than the others but
the rest is smaller is lower on the
metric in scale or vice versa you have
one spot that is lower well guess what
you need to work on that in order to
improve it so if you see that your team
and expertise is the lowest maybe you
need to hire maybe you need some
training maybe you need some external
partners and so on so sorry all of that
throughout the years all of that
experience and seeing ad agencies and
people adopting the concept of digital
analytics maturity all led me to think
about radical and Allen dates and there
are eight premises to radical analytics
and for the rest of this webinar we're
going to go into each of those areas and
then going to provide you some food for
thought and some some ideas so let's dig
into the first one digital analytics is
dead um that's the No
right from the start we start with
something something kind of interesting
why would I say that digital analytics
is dead well when we ask people how do
you define web analytics they came up
with something then we asked how do you
define digital analytics and they came
up with something else and in the end
what I settled on is a simple definition
of what is an antiques it's our
organization arrives at the optimal in
real estate decision informed by data
and each one of those words is super
important the how an organization you
know implies there's there are steps
there's a process and arrives to
something there's a goal there's a
destination the decision aspect is well
you know we don't do it just for fun we
do it because we want to have decisions
in the end and it's informed by data
it's not really data driven because the
the data doesn't decide anything itself
even when we have mission learning and
artificial intelligence essentially we
as humans we delegate that
responsibility or that role to to assist
them but usually it's better to talk
about data informed because the manager
will still make a decision based on
order inside order information that
comes from experience that comes from
external factors like macro economics or
politics and then optimal and realistic
is also super important because what we
want to do is find the balance between
what is the best solution and what
realistic ly we can do so if as an
analyst you make recommendation that
people don't act on most likely it's
because you haven't found the right
balance between what is the best versus
what are the constraints if you knew
what if you knew what are the
constraints maybe your recommendation
would be different so it's a matter of
finding what what are the constraints
and limits to what you can recommend
because if it was a such a great
recommendation there would be absolutely
no reasons not to do it and that's one
of the thing I see in the field is is
analyst saying well I make all those
great analysis but my manager never act
on those well guess what it's because
you there's something you don't know so
next aspect is okay what is the ultimate
goal that we're trying to achieve is
your objective align to the ultimate
goal and the ultimate goal would be
something related to what is the core
business of your organization why is
this company or organization what why
does it exist in the first place which
metrics are going to tell you that you
are making progress and you know most of
the time companies exist because they
want to make more revenue but they also
want to reduce their costs and and those
two things together will lead to some
profit but there's other factors that
come into play we want to increase
satisfaction and the first thing that
comes to mind is increased customer
satisfaction but think of it as if we
have satisfied employees they will work
better and they will stay and they will
produce more value if we have satisfied
investors if we have satisfied
government government bodies because we
respect the regulations in the law we
act responsibly in terms of being a good
corporate citizen for example so
satisfaction is is doesn't only apply to
your customers but it applies more
depending on the on the audience that
you're addressing so this will lead to
greater engagement and if you combine
profit and engagement it means that your
organization is going to be sustainable
in the long term like so
every analyst every in every analysis
every metric should eventually lead back
to one of those things and if it leads
to increase at his faction reduce costs
and increase revenue it is going to be
easier to act on easier to measure than
something that is a longer term ultimate
goal which is the survival of the
organization so a real business
objective is not specific to a channel
or a barking or you know it's just it's
not limited to a marketing function so
that's why when i define analytics i'm
dropping the word digital in front of it
because at the end of the day it doesn't
matter if it's digital everything is
digital anyway and it doesn't matter if
I need to use data from the call center
or from the back office or from anywhere
from surveys and stuff like that my role
as an analyst is to understand the
business context find which data I can
leverage but be creative about the
recommendations in the solution I can
bring to the table this is what is in a
mattox nothing should limit it to being
you know just web-centric or mobile or
just facebook or you know whatever order
where you want to look at it we
shouldn't limit ourselves to that of
course you know we develop expertise and
we develop spiritual things but what
analytics is is really business context
data and creativity combined together to
bring value to the organization so
another one that we can look into is
DMAIC what what is this thing you know
and when we ask is your job hard of
course you know people will say yeah it
is it is difficult but the thing is ask
anyone on the street anyone anywhere ask
them if their job is hard and of course
they're going to say yes my job is hard
it's difficult there are challenges but
you know what this is perfectly fine if
your job was easy you would
be there to do it so our job is not
supposed to be easy because when we look
at what is analytics we have a
definition for that but we do analysis
so what is analysis analysis is how we
break something complex into smaller
parts so that we can understand it and
if we can understand it we can measure
it if we can measure it we can improve
it alright so this is what we do as as a
job and there are ways proven ways to
break something complex into small parts
and one of those proven ways to do it is
called lean to Sigma it's a set of
practices used to systematically improve
processes by eliminating defects it used
a lot of segmentation slicing and dicing
of data it's great for continuous
improvement where the environment is
changing so this Six Sigma was created
years ago for the manufacturing
environment in order to improve
manufacturing but it actually applies
the concept appliance to what we do and
there are five simple steps the first
one is defined define what is the
problem or what is the opponent that
you're trying to to capture define the
boundaries of that problem define a good
objective may be a smart objective then
measure is what kind of data is
available what kind of data we already
have and what kind of data we don't have
can do we have to do some quality
assurance on the data and we can already
do at that stage we can already look
into some basic very basic you know
patterns and trends are there on any
outliers what are the maximum minimums
what is the aboriginal things like that
very simple because we look at a single
source of data in single elements then
analysis is where we put our skills at
work it's where we try to find if
there's any correlations if there's any
patterns if there's any any you know
insight that we can gain out of it
that's where we really put our work into
play
and you know when we talk about
reporting reporting usually is at the
measure step so we basically just take
the data make it look good and spit it
out on the other end into a report when
we talked about analysis there's
actually insight coming out of it
there's actually recommendation there's
actually action and decisions just like
in my definition of analytics so an
honest analysis is super important and
that means to recommendation for
improvement and that's where maybe we
would do an a/b test or a military varia
testing that's where we would you know
do optimization on the site and in our
campaigns and so on and then we do
control control is since we've defined
something to start with the control is
coming back to it and saying well did it
actually work is it a sustainable
benefit that we've put in place so here
we go we have our define measure analyze
improve control so the ma I see is the
acronym for those five steps and you
know what it does in the end is it
reduces the cost of complexity and it in
Queens velocity and velocity is what's
the speed at which you can go through
those five steps if you reduce the time
between the moment you find the problem
in the moment you solve the problem you
have increased velocity if you reduce
the time between the moment you see an
important in the moment you can actually
capture and do something about that
accordingly you increase velocity and if
you increase velocity then you bring
more value faster to the organization so
you know it's it's a way to be able to
become very efficient at what we do and
you can take even the most complex
problems and you're going to be able to
break them down into small parts and go
through those steps and bring value so
in the end what we want to do is make it
easy to do business with you know I had
a manager that kept telling me that and
and you know what there's even you know
the beauty of it is
for linksys Sigma there are books and
training and you know references online
and an all kind of information that you
can leverage so you don't have to create
your own analytics methodology yourself
there's already something out there that
you can start from so the next one is
never ask always proposed and as I
mentioned you know there are maybe some
aspects of radical analytics that some
people may be you you're going to say no
that doesn't apply to me and that's fine
but this is based on something that I've
seen so often in the field so what is
never asked always proposed what
happened when you make a recommendation
you say we should do this well do you go
to your manager and you ask you know
here's my recommendation do you agree or
you don't agree and you're going to get
a guess no answer so it's a binary
choice there's no other option either
you do it or you don't so it's a very
limited possibility and once the
decision is made there's usually you
know it's hard to revert that decision
on the other end if you just ask a no
good question you know what is your
objective that's a really open question
uh what are your KPIs it's an open
question we will they will make up
something they will tell you something
and and sometimes the conversation is
going to be about well you know I don't
know what kind of metrics what kind of
reports do you have oh well we have you
know about 120 different reports and in
200 different metrics and so on well i'm
going to pick a little bit of that and a
little bit of this just and well let's
measure this also because just in case
just in case we need it okay i see that
so often so the problem when we ask open
questions is that we we put ourselves in
a position where we're going to be told
what to do but we won't be told why it's
important from a business standpoint
while if we slip
conversation if we instead of opening
instead of coming with a yes/no question
or just an open a wide open question
what if instead we we made a proposal
what if instead we we said well you know
I've been looking into it I think your
objectives should be something around
those lines what do you think about that
so at least you engage a conversation
and you can from that you can have a
better understanding of why it's
important and instead of being told what
to do so sometimes we talk about
reporting monkeys it's a very negative
term if you are ever label that oh
you're reporting monkey that's not
really a good career opportunity so
reporting monkey is being essentially
you know someone who's been cornered
into being told oh I need this report Oh
give me this metric they never tell you
why it's important they just asked for
it and this this is not the right way to
do it so you want to you want to flip
the conversation around so what I've
started looking into is instead of
thinking in terms of making a
recommendation and defining smart
objectives I've been looking into a
product thinking which is essentially
what startups are using in order to
define new products for a market so they
start with the user first what is the
problem that we're trying to solve and
for whom are we going to for who are we
going to solve the problem so who's the
audience what is the problem then why
are we doing this what is the vision why
is it important for us so so now we won
started with the user first but now
we're thinking about okay what's what's
in it for us as an organization and what
is the strategy are how are we going to
do it so when we combine the two we have
the the problem solution fit so are we
we have a problem we have an audience
and we have a way to solve the problem
for that audience so that's awesome
then what is the output of that what is
the goal what do we want to achieve and
how do we know that we've actually
achieved it so we can measure success so
you combine product thinking and the
concept and you have a nice statement in
order to achieve something our vision
our product or service will solve a
specific problem for a specific audience
by giving them something they want and
we will know it works when we see this
goal being achieved so it's different
from a smart objective it's a different
way to approach it and what I like about
it is that we start with the customer
charge the user first in mind and then
we see how we can help them so maybe
that if you're able to fill the blanks
in that statement you will probably have
a fairly good objective to start from
and improve from from there right next
aspect is in each around dog food when I
worked for Microsoft for a while and
they had that mantra of eg rondelle true
which essentially means no do what you
preach and as analysts and anyone who's
done any project management we know
about the triple constraint model where
you have cost time and scope so if you
want to reduce costs what are you going
to do well you can increase time or you
can reduce the scope if you want to
reduce the time I want it faster what
can you do you can increase the cost so
you could you put more resources at it
or you reduce the scope so you can
deliver faster so when when I talk to
analysts they usually complain about the
fact that they have too much work
they're not able to deliver the quality
they would like to they get content
constantly asked to do addition
task and so on so why not do what you
preach optimize your own job so in
Toronto true so if you were asked to cut
ten percent or twenty percent whatever
the percentage of your job how would you
do it would you be able to do it uh
there's there's that thing from a jack
welch when the all the e-business and
e-commerce was was growing up they were
obviously everything ebusiness was kind
of challenging the old models and Jack
Welch came up with the idea of destroy
your business if you had to start your
business again from scratch how would
you do it what would you do differently
so think of your own job because after
all you know the worst thing to do is to
complain about our own job if we keep
telling my job is hard basically we lose
all credibility because after all if we
want to improve and optimize the
business but we're not even in able to
improve and optimize our own job that's
there's zero credibility so different
ways of of optimizing your own job you
could review the roles and
responsibilities you can identify all
the tasks that you are doing and your
team is doing and see who is responsible
wins accountable who is consulted and
informed so a racy matrix and you can
look into it the building and racing
matrix is a list of tasks who's you know
what what is the person who has a role
to actually do it and approve it and
needs to be involved and so on so that's
one way to do improvement but of course
you're going to need to set some time
apart in order to do that I'm going to
say no that's one of the difficult
things to do is you know when someone in
the organization comes to you and say oh
I need this I need that well you know
ask why they need it push back a little
bit but push back in a way that is
constructive so we demonstrate that you
want to
then why it's important and maybe that's
going to be that's going to end up
having more priority than something else
if you if if you work with a task list
well most likely the number of items on
the on the list is is higher than your
ability to remove the items from the
list so there's always more coming in
and there is no end to it so what are
you going to do to to solve that we can
look at a lean management and there's a
concept of the eight waste of lean you
know eliminating the effects eliminating
overproduction one in our area one thing
that I see is a number five
transportation you know taking data from
one place and putting it into another
place just because well because of what
if it doesn't bring any value then why
would we take data from one place and
bring it to the inner to another place
like extracting the data using an API
and putting it into a data lake that's
fancy that's trendy that's cool but does
it really bring any value maybe it's a
it's worth asking a question and then
take the lead don't wait to be told what
to do make propositions based on what
you controlled manage and influence and
I'm going to get back to that point of
control manage and influence because
super important so I mentioned a racy
matrix so who's responsible accountable
consulted informed the importance of
that is you have your your own role
conception what you think your job is
and then there's a disconnect with the
expectation what other people think that
your job should be and then there's
another disconnect and there's actually
what you really do in your job so all of
that over time creates a lot of
confusion about who's supposed to do
what and why they do it and why it's
valuable for the free organization and
here's an example of an actual workshop
that I conducted where we looked at what
are from a business standpoint what are
the
in actions what are the enabling
capabilities how do you make it possible
and the analysis aspect and you see
there's a lot of work being done on the
enabling capabilities so is it the most
valuable work why do we spend some so
much time you know implementing tags and
doing data quality and stuff with that
and so little time do and less in fact
less time doing analysis and outcome in
actions which brings me to the next one
don't seek executive by in another one
that is a bit controversial and Tom
Davenport is really respected and he
wrote a book competing on analytics and
there's a energy and an interesting
statement in there you know becoming
data-driven means that you change a
culture of the organization you change
the behavior this key and you need to
impact the skills of many employees so
it's a major transition it requires
leadership from executives at the very
top who have a passion for the
quantitative approach and so you know
when you read something that it's clear
that you want to have executive sponsor
sponsorship because it's a major
transformation so usually what I what
happened is yes executive sponsors can
can overcome roadblocks they can work on
big issues but they will also expect you
know novel solutions and and grandiose
projects this require more time it's
costly and it's whiskey and and you get
just a tiny fraction of the organization
you actually have they're driven
managers senior managers for the rest of
the maybe ninety nine percent of the
rest usually it works better when it's a
grassroot a fourth the most disruptive
innovation the better idea is oftentimes
they come from the people who are
actually doing the work it's small
experiments small improvement they
you can have quick iteration so it's
small it's incremental and this will add
up so it's a lot easier to improve a
hundred things by 1% then it is to
improve a single thing by one hundred
percent and the thing with if you
improve if you make small improvements
if you make one hundred small
improvements actually the Sun won't be a
hundred it's going to it's going to have
an exponential effect because every
incremental improvement you do is is
going to add up to an exponential result
so yes if you if you're lucky and you
have executive sponsorship that's great
but most of the time you don't so start
from the bottom so do you manage control
and influence the underlying factors of
success so let's start with the control
phase the control aspect the control
aspect is is what you actually do you
have control over it you have the tools
you have the data you have you know how
to solve those you know how to do those
tasks and your role should be to deliver
more value at a lower cost so again
that's how you would improve your own
job but also bring value to the
organization by major combination for
improving order tasks in the
organization and you can quantify your
work because you have control over it so
it's a lot easier to to measure what you
control the manage aspect is what you
are accountable for areas where or tasks
where you can allocate resources and you
can motivate other people to work a
common goal yo of course if you have
defined the goal in the first place and
then influence is area is where you're a
subject matter expert so maybe it's not
directly what you are responsible or
accountable for doing but you are
considered to be an expert in that in
that subject so those once you control
and manage those tasks the other task
where you have influence might be areas
of potential growth as from a carrier
endpoint or just to bring more value to
the organization so what you control
manage and influence as a huge influence
over your ability to deliver value for
the organization then we go into uncover
the unknown unknowns what it is you know
there are things that we know there's
things that oh I don't know about that
and I can recognize that I don't know
but there's also things that you don't
know that you don't know that there's
actually no way until you stumble on it
until you do an experiment there's no
way you could know what was hiding
behind that so call it pilot project
solid proof of concept or call it an
experiment either way it doesn't matter
but either way what we want to do is
remember what is the definition of
analysis is how to great company
something complex into smaller parts so
that week honors understand how it works
and and when we do that if we do a pilot
project with concept or experiment with
basically what we're trying to do is
lower the risks we're giving ourselves a
right to a right to fail but in reading
what it is it's a right to learn because
you're going to find out something that
you didn't know before it's not a
failure if you do an experiment and in
the end it doesn't work you haven't
failed anything now you know it doesn't
work and that's valuable you learn
something and it allows you to think in
terms of just like a start-up think a
July think what is the minimum viable
solution that you can bring to the table
in order to bring value faster rather
than having a big super big project
right so think in terms of the same
philosophy as if you were a start-up
yourself within the organization and in
your role is to bring value which brings
me to agile and write a jungle die there
is too often projects where our
organization where I see analytics as
almost like okay one day we will get
there but first we need to do this and
that and so on and they always postpone
there's always a reason to not do it
today so you will have those 12
principles in the slides I won't go
through all of them but what i did is i
looked at the 12th principles of agile
and from agile development so it's
another area where we don't have to
reinvent the wheel we can leverage
concepts from agile development and
apply it to a nowadays so what I've done
is simply we rework a couple of those
statements to make them fit better with
with our field of expertise which is
analytics and we're getting to the point
of analysis are change agents and the
reason I'm saying that is no at the end
of the day what is the difference
between a manager and an analyst the big
difference I see is that an analyst was
given the privilege of making
recommendations but the manager has the
power of decision so imagine if you're
the analyst and you make a
recommendation if you were the manager
would you say yes to your recommendation
if you wouldn't say yes to your own
recommendation then it's not a good
recommendation and and what i see i'm
teaching mba students and marketing
masters and what I see is there's going
to be a breed one day there's going to
be a new breed of managers that will be
more data-driven they will be more data
informed they will want to understand
how analytics works and they will give
more trust to those recommendation they
and they will you know empower there
there's in their team to be may be more
self-sufficient or make more decisions
because they will trust them which
brings us to you know the evolution or
the current path of people in the field
you know do you prefer to have people
who have a depth of knowledge or breadth
of understanding so
do you prefer to have someone who
understand about the concepts of
marketing or someone who is able to deep
dive into something like Google
Analytics that's very different they
want to have people who have an
understanding of broadly speaking what
is the marketing mix and what is
attribution what is customer lifetime
value or do you want someone who's going
to be able to do super awesome great
campaigns on Facebook very different so
depth of knowledge and you can apply
that to to your own the vertical
industry for the organization that you
work for if you work in the automotive
industry do you want someone to have an
understanding of marketing in general or
someone who has a deep knowledge of what
is the automotive industry that's very
different so over time we need to
develop those those we have we need to
have a good balance in our team of
people who had death of knowledge and
breadth of develop skills and breadth of
knowledge and getting close to the
conclusion I want to share with you the
team dynamic aspect so you saw a picture
of a workshop where I mentioned business
outcomes and actions I mentioned
enabling capabilities and analysis so if
we look at that i'm using this this way
of presenting the team because it all
starts from the business standpoint they
define the strategy in the goals which
are communicated to people who are going
to be able to basically communicate
business requirements and objective to
people who can bring it to life they are
the enablers they understand the
technologies make understand the
constraint the constraints of those
technologies they understand the
information architecture the features
the how to put the tags on the website
how to use R & R to you to do sequel
statement to extract the data so these
supply remains the tools in the data so
that people with a stronger analysis
mindset maybe some status of knowledge a
problem-solving approach they are
go to sanitize a lot of information and
communicate effectively actionable
insight and recommendation back to the
business so here's the point the point
is nobody is able to do all of that on
their own you likely have a strong point
a strong area and you have maybe an area
that okay I'm good at that and then
something that is no this is not what I
want to do this is not my ball game I
would rather have someone do someone
else do it so the thing is fine in which
area is your most comfortable and and
and go for that you won't be able to do
everything on your own that's absolutely
impossible so if you think of someone a
data scientist what is the data
scientist well it's someone is super
strong on the enabling capabilities
because they understand you know the big
data environment in the tools to
leverage big data but they are also very
strong on the analysis side of thing
because it can build data models and so
on are they necessarily the best people
from a business standpoint maybe not and
that's fine if you think about a digital
marketer digital marketer will be strong
on the business side of things on the
marketing side of things and somewhat
you know it's usually fairly good on the
analysis side of thing but typically
digital marketers don't ask them to put
the tags on the website because they
they don't know JavaScript they don't
know how to use you know your tag
management system they don't know about
api's maybe they can do something about
it but that's not their ballgame they
would rather have someone else do it if
that other person can be very efficient
someone in their web development team or
IT who's super awesome at putting the
tags on a website so you see the picture
right so let's wrap up digital analytics
is that a project it's a doing analytics
is there it's it's not a simple thing
that you need to do it's a it's a way of
life as Guy Kawasaki was was putting it
to become data-driven as an organization
it can
not be a project it cannot be a single
person aspect it cannot be just a CEO
coming in or senior manager saying okay
here we go from this day we're going to
be data-driven so I've shared with you
the radical analytics premises there's
eight of them you can give it a try and
hopefully you know if I was going to
start again and ask you what's your
objective maybe you have a smarter way
to define an objective and think about
all the things that we've seen and and
you know what as as a bonus there's
there's this guy David Parmenter who
wrote a ton of books on key performance
indicator honestly I never thought that
there would be so many things to write
about but anyway he wrote many books on
key performance indicator and there's
something really useful on how to define
KPIs and just like a lot of the things
that I mentioned the point is we need to
take a step back think about what we do
and find ways to do it better this is
what digital analytics and what
analytics is all about make things
better improve it and start with your
own job so on this thank you and we can
go for a couple of questions exit and
thank you Stefan that was wonderful I
always loved these webinars because I'm
always learning something new it was
such a wonderful i love being in the
learning community yes at this point I'm
actually going to take over your screen
and we're going to start at the pole
that we do during the question and
answer session perfect now one of the
questions I already see it up hidden up
there a couple places is me go ahead and
launch the poll first there we go is do
we have a recording of the session or
can you go back and look at it and yes
we do record all the sessions if you go
to simply learn calm and hit the support
button you can request recording for the
specific session and they'll send you
the link for that it does take up to 12
hours so if you want a copy of the
recording go to simply learn calm and
under support may have a some great
questions coming in a start but it's a
couple from
paratus I hope I said the name correctly
the first one is at the beginning of
your session you had a five-point kind
of star up yes that you want to know
what the name of that how would you name
this star approach you know this is
David it was stated driven scope and
objectives team and expertise that one
mm-hmm so it's the digital analytics
naturally model and you can go to
digital analytics I can I'll no I'm not
sharing my screen but if you go to bit
ly and you will get the link in the the
presentation you can go to bit ly /
dan80 and uppercase and you will get to
the digital on things analytics website
okay excellent give me just a moment to
scroll down here and then during the
course you had a lot of questions you
had a lot of mentions that we talked
about digital analytics or data
analytics we talked about lean six sigma
we talked about different PMP and stuff
like that what kind of certificates or
course for learning would you suggest to
an individual who is just starting out
into the field and they're trying to
figure out hey what am I going to do and
what I want to be in analytics I want to
go in there and I want to help companies
solve their problems yeah do I start
yeah that's a great question and and
what's interesting is until recently
there were very very few training and
formal academic education available to
become a digital analyst and things are
changing of course we see there's a lot
of training around data science you know
how to become a data scientist and so on
but it's different it's likely different
then then what we do we tend to be more
on the marketing side of things and we
tend to be much more about leveraging
you know digital data from websites
mobile and so on which doesn't refrain
us run from the other sources of data
and doing more so i would i would start
with you know the first question to ask
is what drives you so if i go back to
the team dynamics a slide where i have
that triangle you know what draw
in the morning is it a good technical
challenge I have a technical background
I was a computer scientist and
eventually I did I went to do an MBA so
i went from the very technical side of
thing of being a system in straighter a
webmaster at one time so very technical
but eventually when to do an mba because
I wanted to be to understand more about
the business so what drives you in the
morning is it the business challenge of
technology called challenge or the
statistics and the analysis aspect once
you know that there's that I think will
help you define or find out what kind of
training you need to look into and of
course on simply learned you have a ton
of different opportunities for learning
about project management learning about
statistics learning about of course
digital marketing in general and digital
marketing specifically so there's a lot
of training that you can get from there
um but I think it starts with first what
you won't be able to do everything so
fine what aspect drives you in the
morning well that's excellent but I
second I could have used that about 30
years ago that maybe a little bit
yesterday hey I remember you back in the
80s it was whoever your teacher was they
give you advice I thought you were to go
and I realize it we're in such a
different world than theirs am a
different moving pieces and I would say
also the other thing is when I go to
conferences and I talked to so many
people on what I seek today is that very
few people were actually trained
formally or informally to do what they
do today so no but nobody's stumbled
onto something that magically made them
being digital marketer and digital
analysts they they have backgrounds in
all different kind of feel they have
some of them yes of course they have
background in marketing in statistics
and so on but many people have
backgrounds in in psychology and in
English literature for example in
philosophy you know all kind of thing
that you would think at first that that
never prepared those people to work in
that field
they do and they enjoy it excellent and
that's kind of my experience to over the
years I I certainly am NOT where I
started at when I went to college or any
of that you know very very different
world than I ever thought I'd be in yeah
yeah make yourself your own project I
like that make yourself your own project
yes yeah think of yourself as a start-up
you know your role right you increase
your value in the market add fun doing
it and be compensated you know at a
decent level so that you can make a
living but but think of your own career
as a business that will change a lot of
things in the way you develop your your
career path XO no that's excellent
advice um we have a couple more specific
questions as far as the industry and
specifically I both of my from
e-commerce and I guess one of them let
me just go back up here they're looking
for an example in e-commerce for when
you're talking about digital analytics
is dead how does it optimal realistic
decisions link in an organization
sustained and only on profit so if
you're in ecommerce is there a point
where you're just based on the profit as
your final goal or is that something
that that I will trade that can only
work for for some time because you know
if your only goal is to make a profit
but you don't have enough consideration
for the satisfaction aspect then
eventually that's going to erode yes
you're going to make some revenue for
some time but eventually you know
there's going to be your reputation
there's going to be customer
satisfaction there's going to be you
know all kinds of aspect and and today
with social media and you know d is of
destroying a brand I don't think working
solely on revenue in you know if we
extend the idea there's a lot of
questioning about the model of companies
that are always working to
show just a greater return on investment
for the investors that works for so long
but eventually in the name to be
sustainable in the long run and
sustainability also involve having
customers who are satisfied but also
investors who are satisfied right and
employees who are satisfied so I don't
in an e-commerce context i D yes of
course you want to improve profitability
but their names like if I have to define
the dashboard and define KPIs I will
always have something that will relate
to other factors like you know be it net
promoter score be it customer
satisfaction whatever you want to use
but there needs to be something else
related to satisfaction excellent
excellent for anybody is doing a
start-up to startups take a lot I
weren't a lot of startup companies
myself and you don't have that full
field of expertise it's amazing how how
easy it is to get stuck yes I the
startup and then getting that those
those people who have skills that
complement your own is so important in
distributing business yeah abso and
that's why that's why you know it might
be better to for start-up for example if
your core business is you know it might
just be wiser to find someone who's
going to take care of your web analytics
implementation for example don't waste
your time trying to do it yourself just
find someone there's it'll different
levels of skills and prices in the
market you can find someone who's is
going to be very cheap you can find
someone who's going to cost more and
they will bring different levels of
expertise and value but if it if you've
never done any and and that's usually
what I say to all my clients is and when
I speak at conferences that if you've
never done a web analytics
implementation it finds one to help you
out do it for you and maybe shadow what
they are doing but don't try to do it
yourself because there is no way you're
going to get it right x
advice that's excellent advice it
certainly I don't reinvent the wheel you
know yeah yeah the cosmic once yeah
let's go ahead i got like just a couple
more questions so a few minutes overtime
and i didn't close the poll so if you
need your screen to show something we
have that okay kind of a little bit more
on the difference between data analyst
and data scientist how different yeah
and well maybe i can just bring that
that slide you see my screen and yes
your screens [ __ ] out so so yeah the
data scientist data scientist has a Dean
tend to have a broader skill sets in
terms of enabling capabilities so how to
leverage the technology related to Big
Data so be it you know Hadoop or
bigquery or are but so they know about
those tools they and they have they were
trained and they have the knowledge how
to build models from scratch from the
raw data they do they understand a lot
about status states they understand it
up a lot about for example building
predictive models but they tend to have
less knowledge about the specifics of
the business so basically you provide
and maybe I'm you know it's a bit of a
stereotype but you give them some
interesting data and they know how to
use the right tools to rheank to come to
to bring extract value out of that data
using statistical models so that's how I
see data science digital analysts they
tend to be more on you know depend to
have typically more knowledge about
marketing but I wouldn't limit it to
marketing but usually they have more
knowledge of about marketing aspect and
the specific business they're in so if
they are in the automotive industry and
so on and but maybe they don't know as
much about core statistics concepts I
was surprised when i asked web analyst
at the time couple of years ago I asked
web
how much math and stats do you need to
know in order to be a good a good web
analyst and surprisingly the answer was
well you actually don't know you don't
need to know much because the tool is
going to tell you so today we see
difference between digital marketers and
digital analysts who wants to use a
black box that will give them the result
versus data scientists who actually want
to build that black box right so that
that's two very important components and
when we when we use tools like Google
antics and adobe analytics we use a
black box we don't need to be data
scientists in order to use those tools
while people working at Google them and
working at adobe building those tools of
course they need to be more of a data
science profile excellent um yeah that's
just kind of what I always see in the
industry it's wonderful i like the way
you put it it definitely spells it out
makes a lot easier for people who are
looking to figure out where they're
going either individually or as a
company I mean knowing this stuff and if
you're working with a large group of
people being able to see what their
strengths are and how to leverage that
is really important and i guess the
worst thing to do would be to say oh we
need big data you know I've heard that
we need big data well no you don't need
big data what you need first is what is
the problem you're trying to solve and
maybe big data is going to be one of the
enabling capability that you need in
order to solve that problem but it
starts with the it starts with the
business for us what is the question
what is the problem you're trying to
solve then let's see what are the tools
we can use to do it to solve it actually
sounds like a business meeting ahead
yesterday morning that's good because I
leverage Hadoop into the soy specialties
in Hadoop and I said well how much data
are you leveraging yeah and he's like
well I don't know a nice i closed it
more than a terabyte us know yeah
probably don't need something that big
and i said well what are you gonna
leverage out it because i don't know i
just open excel and do it there yeah
pretty much yeah you run they're ready
to expel just fine as I've been I've
been quoted
you know the simplest definition of big
data ever I came up with the the answer
to that whatever doesn't fit in Excel
because when you think of it as soon as
you have to get out of Excel everybody
knows excel but when you have to get out
of Excel because the problem is to bid
then you have to rethink the way you
solve the problem and you have to think
about maybe different tools that you
need to solve the problem so to me
that's a very simple transition when
when Excel isn't good enough anymore to
solve your problems maybe that's where
you start to lean toward using new tools
like maybe tableau or big data concepts
excellent one last quick question here
before we go ahead and close the session
we're about seven minutes I love this
death this is this is why I enjoy these
webinars what's your opinion on MS and
data analytics is a hands-on experience
better at teaching data analytics and
coursework this is like an interesting
question that we all deal with and we're
learning is you know more from going to
a course or am I going to learn more
from actually doing it I think you need
both then there was an interesting
article about how Google antics mean
room marketing and and you know previous
the argument behind it and I think it
makes some sense is that a lot of people
learned about digital analytics because
they went into google something like
Google Analytics and that's where they
learn about it they but they learn about
a tool and they learn about how a tool
approach and I'll takes it to to to
bring some some value right but do those
people know about marketing concepts do
they know about statistics there they
might be awesome at using a tool but do
they understand what are the
implications that a tool like Google
takes rings or surface right so yes you
can learn you can go to a course that
will be really specific to
whatever tool that you use and you're
going to be able to put it into action
you know maybe faster and right away but
we should never underestimate the
importance of having this this team
shape right so you might be super good
at Google antics but if you don't
understand marketing concepts and the
statistics and the other aspects of
optimization project management you know
a lot of the things that I talked about
if you don't have a minimum
understanding of those things I think in
the long run you're you won't have the
best career opportunity that you might
have otherwise excellent excellent yeah
that's there that's so true in juggling
different your own life and businesses
that's all excellent i love the way you
present that we have gone over so i
notice we have a few people already left
the thing because they probably have
their own stuff going on in their lives
webinars you know where they finish
their glass of wine if it's evening
where they're at and Oprah's are very
welcome it was telling you thank you
very much for answering a lot of those
questions came from him I'm going to go
ahead and close the webinar now I want
to thank everybody for being here we
greatly appreciate you Stefan for your
expertise well damn I bet I appreciate
all the attendees for being here also
and we look forward to seeing you in our
classes alright thank you everyone see
you soon take care bye bye
you